caos y violencia la frontera entre
afganistán y pakistán se ha convertido
en escenario de enfrentamientos entre
ciudadanos y autoridades de ambos países
la situación en el paso fronterizo de
chamán es límite aquí miles de afganos
llevan tres semanas varados pasando
hambre y frío
todas las personas atrapadas aquí están
en una gran miseria nosotros sólo
pedimos que nos den una oportunidad para
que podamos volver a casa la diania al
bordado y estamos protestando porque
todos están cansados de estar parados
aquí el frío nos está destruyendo de
verdad muchas de estas personas viven
del comercio transfronterizo pero
pakistán cerró sus fronteras ante una
posible avalancha de refugiados afganos
familias enteras se agolpan en los
puestos fronterizos sin ningún tipo de
asistencia paquistaní ni afgana
he estado parado aquí durante 18 días
alrededor de 2.000 personas están
sentadas aquí
ya no hay comida ni té nadie que nos
cuide mallo man
hay ancianos varados aquí niños mujeres
queremos que se abra la frontera de
ambos lados
afganistán atraviesa una de sus peores
crisis en décadas la llegada al poder de
los talibanes ha aislado al país del
resto del mundo lo cual pone en riesgo
al 97% de la población de sumergirse en
la pobreza para el 2022 y que el hambre
y la desesperación aumenten en todo el
país